all right guys
bang bang lunch money time on thursday
oh wall street's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right
bang bang don't forget blockfi is now
sponsoring lunch money
if you go and you sign up for an account
and you fund it before july 18th
they will pay you double interest in the
month of august what does that mean
you can go to the link in the
description you have to use the link in
the description because that's the promo
link
if you use that link and create a block
fly account you can deposit money
whether it's crypto a stable coin
whatever
and they will pay you up to eight eight
point six percent apy for the year
right but in the month of august they
will give you 2x
what you would normally earn so go sign
up for a blackfy account fund it before
july 18th
get 2x the interest and let's get going
what's going on with coinbase let's get
going okay
we have a canadian uh i think we're
gonna say canadian accent
suit no just a jacket by the way my
beautiful and intelligent polina
marinova is here as a co-host today okay
i forgot that part you don't have to
remember that verb
um crypto exchange coinbase you're so
memorable though
go ahead i don't know that means
coinbase has started plans for a stock
market listing that could come as
early as next or as this year making it
the first major u.s cryptocurrency
exchange
to go public mr bitcoin what do you
think
i thought that i i meant to say that
you're so uh
um unforgettable that's what i was
trying to say you're unforgettable
uh coinbase going public first of all
they're not necessarily going public
they're exploring the
option or the opportunity to do that
through a direct list of sources
via reuters yes so through a potential
uh direct list of jesus i can't talk
today what is going on
through a potential direct listing they
are thinking about going public
there's two ways to look at this right
one is uh that they're gonna do it the
other is that they're just testing the
waters
um we are investors in the company so i
won't say too much i don't know anything
so i can't really say anything anyways
um but i think it's interesting right
like if they were the first large crypto
company to get out in the public markets
you got to think that people would be
excited about it and there would be
value there but
time will tell what is okay so uh other
than that
coinbase was last valued at 8 billion do
we think
that so why would they go public this
year well i think a lot of companies you
see palantir a lot of these companies
have been private for a long time
they're interested in going public right
now because the public markets are
exploding
right just yeah literally asset prices
are getting pumped to the moon through
quantitative easing and stuff and so
when good times are rolling
uh in the stock market people want to
get it
[Music]
all right um next up
youtube's going to take down this video
for copyright material like copyright
material
yeah who's i have a monopoly on good
singing what's going on with the ivy
league
ivy league cancels football and other
fall sports due to covet
so yesterday i turned to anthony and i
was like i did not realize that when
somebody says in ivy league school
it's because they're in an ivy league
for football like i never even thought
of that
that's so dumb we played the ivy league
schools when i was in college
they're not very good at football who
was the biggest of them
the patriot league which is basically
the poor man's
ivy league i was i went to the harvard
of the south if anybody's interested you
went to georgia
yes let's not get it the harvard of the
south yeah okay
sure um so the ideally i could have
gotten into georgia and i didn't even
try
at the saturday but
the ivy league officially cancelled fall
athletics including the football
schedule
in a very extremely difficult decision i
mean there's two ways to look at it one
is if the students aren't allowed on
campus to take classes you can't really
have the football season
right it's like that kind of they were
forced there uh and the second thing is
look i get it you kind of have no choice
at the same time are the football
players playing
on the field actually at risk of
contracting kovid
arguable but there is a lot that goes
into
the support staff the coaches all of the
people who
uh the athletic trainers the people who
provide the food all that kind of stuff
you just get more and more people all
colliding together football teams are
large they usually have you know
anywhere between
80 to 100 people so i get it so when i
was in high school and i was getting all
these college marketing materials sent
to me
for football were you getting recruited
no like college marketing
go to my college and one of them was one
of the ivy leagues i i forget which one
it was
but what i do not did not forget is that
the marketing material said for their
football team
somebody holding a sign at a football
game that said we will beat you with our
brains and i was like oh no
oh yeah that they're real big on trying
to be nerds
that's so bad torched anyway
all right gail darius dale my boy he
went to yale you just smack him around
real easy
okay i i i harvard i've met played at
harvard multiple times twice i think
i've met him and you did not smack him
around no we beat them
nah yeah we did okay uh princeton
a lot of people don't know is princeton
stadium looks like an old school roman
coliseum
that was pretty cool to play okay this
is not we're trying to inform the people
okay i'm informing now i'm teaching them
using my life experiences what's going
on with the disney bubble
okay so what the hell is this disney
bubble so the nba season
the nba season is set to resume at the
end of the month after being suspended
since march 11th
and the 22 team selected to finish out
the season
will convene at the walt disney world
resort in orlando
it's already started so basically what
they did is they said okay we're all
going to go into this place no one's
allowed in or out
bubble meals sorry yeah we're basically
no one's allowed in or out and we're
going to play basketball
right and they've got all kinds of
practice courts they've got uh
arena set up uh but remember these are
like nba players they're used to a
certain style of
lesser lifestyle so like literally
there's photos now surfacing of them
uh with plates of food that literally
the best thing i heard
bubble meals the best thing i heard
somebody said yo it looks like you went
to hudson news and got your meal right
like the place at the airport yeah it
has salad pasta grilled chicken inside
like potato chips and watermelon slices
honestly like it seems like a pretty
good dinner to me what are they
complaining you're a professional
athlete what do you normally eat
professional athletes uh a couple years
ago there was a guy
um von miller who he missed practiced
one day
and reporters asked him yo what happened
why didn't you show up why didn't you
have to go to practice today
so i got sick and they were like what
did you do did you eat something like
what
he goes i had mozzarella sticks
yesterday you know you can't put regular
gas in a ferrari
same thing here you can't be putting
this nasty ass stuff in these
people's bodies so this is what's wrong
with america let me just tell you
you cannot mix salad with big ass
watermelon slices that is disgusting my
other favorite tweet that i saw was one
of the nba players took a picture of the
food that he had
and said lebron had eaten this
being like i know i know you ain't
giving the same food to lebron that
you're giving to me
yeah of course so we'll see look hey
good for them for trying
uh i tend to think that people want
sports back right and it's kind of like
a mental relief
frankly for a lot of people who are
going through hard times right now so if
they can do it safely like
more power to them but if you're a nba
player right now
uh what was it paul pierce uh went on tv
and uh paul pierce and stephen a jackson
i think were two guys who basically said
look
if you think that no one's violating the
uh the bubble you're crazy
and they're like what do you mean and
they were like look man come on these
are grown ass man you tell them they
can't see their wives they can't see
their girlfriends they can't see the
you know women come on it's not
happening okay so
when sports comes back would you rather
watch sports or hang out with me
sports all right what's going on with
twitter
what's going on with twitter putting you
in a bubble
okay i've been living in a bubble with
just you for like
months now okay what's going on with
twitter okay
twitter may be working on a paid product
and investors
seemed seem thrilled about it shares
rose on the news
yeah there's a subscription platform
codenamed gryphon
and i don't understand griffin oh wait
are you sure it's on grifon
positive wait why is it griffin it's not
spoiler griffin let me tell you that
h makes an f sound yeah gryphon
go ahead it's described as a new team
that's building a subscription platform
that can be reused by other teams in the
future i don't understand what that
means
basically i think what they're trying to
do is they're trying to figure out how
do you do subscription payments on
twitter what's unclear is does that
because they're going to create
something that could be competitive sub
stack
it could be a competitor uh to like
patreon where you say hey look i'm going
to put my tweets behind a paywall
if you want to read my tweets pay me for
them right like it could be for a whole
bunch of different things it could be
video like hey i'm going to post videos
on youtube or on twitter
that could be interesting but you got to
pay me to see them sure maybe
you've always said though on the flip
side kind of not
you charging for tweets but you've said
that if twitter tomorrow
went behind a paywall you would pay to
access i pay a hundred dollars a month
wow it says twitter yeah why
because it is the single most powerful
platform that i have access to in terms
of the information that i glean from it
the people that i interact with meet and
talk to uh
and then from a distribution standpoint
we met on twitter how much is that worth
a hundred dollars a month i've already
paid too much all right what's going on
with uber
uber is going to offer boat rides in
london as a new commuter service so uber
boat is coming guys
i'm on a boat no you know
no what is that no do you know what i'm
on a boat is yes it's a song with the
flippy floppies
you don't know she doesn't get it she
doesn't get it have you ever seen step
brothers
oh yeah that's a stupid boats and hoes
that's not what i was talking about i
know that's not what you're talking
about but like
people on the internet get it you're
over here singing some song from 1942.
all right let's go what what is uh what
is uber uh doing they're just
they just got like a ferry it's like a
ferry it's kind of like a ferry
um the service will be operated by the
river bus service i don't
know so they're basically just
partnering with like a ferry-like
service and then you can use it but you
can use them
to book it yeah i mean look it makes
sense what did i tell what i said
yesterday
uber is a logistics company they move
things from point a to point b
those things could be people they could
be uh food they could be logistical
packages
uh it's all that stuff that's what
uber's business is they are in the
business of moving things
why not move it over water sure but
if it works would they go and start
doing international shipping
uh across water international shipping
what's the difference between taking uh
a package across manhattan
to putting the package on a boat and
taking it somewhere yeah then
you never know what's going on my man's
usain bolt fastest man alive and also
the guy who's
absolutely having a blast he ha okay
okay
don't i don't know what you're doing
right now that's his move oh that's his
move
he when he wins he goes like this okay
well
you said are you ready oh my god i
forgot my joke for today
come on let's go i got plenty of jokes
okay um okay so he just had a daughter
and guess what he named her it's a
they are calling it her name is
incredibly awesome
and also a subtle flex
champion kind of oh really no
oh there he is doing the move i told you
all right so usain bolt
named his daughter olympia lightning
bolt isn't that awesome
what what a savage it's so much better
than elon musk
what a maniac but what an awesome name
not only do you get the use of his
fantastic nickname lightning bolt but
you also get a reminder of both unreal
olympics performance olympia
lightning bolt oh man you know she
better be
fast she better be fast but if she has
no interest in sports whatsoever
it'll matter your dad's usain bolt you
better get
running uh can you imagine all the kids
talking [ __ ] in the
in middle school oh your dad's usain
bolt i can beat you in a race right now
you ain't nothing
olympia like olympics and
we get that lightning bolt how amazing
this is his girlfriend i have a dream
baby
what oh my god such a cute baby knock
knock
i i'm not there
knock knock what no you guys knock knock
who's there
orange aren't you special
no orange me pretty no
what is it knock knock okay who's there
orange orange aren't you tired of
putting up with me yet see
yeah i am thank you i tell nice jokes it
wasn't as good as mine
um because what like the
i got the duck i got the pig like you
don't got no farm animals
we're not farmers we live in the middle
of manhattan what what
farm everybody knows a farm animal makes
a really good funny joke
like what like a fruit does not did you
see the joke on the internet where they
go like what's a dog mate what's a
uh cat make what sound does a cow make
and they go what song what noise does a
whale make and they drink water they
spit it on each other
yeah that's dumb i saw that on tick tock
okay i'm off all right guys
i'm out i'm not in the surveillance
world it's today thursday
yeah yes happy thursday do you have a
joke
i don't can we talk real quick i'm
surprised that you didn't talk about the
glee star who's missing from our boat
okay that's really sad i don't want to
talk about the woman drowned we think
well we don't think she's missing from
no i think that she drowned
we don't know what happened yeah we
don't know a woman went on a boat with
her four-year-old
and they found the boat floating later
and the woman's not there but the
four-year-old was
uh it had a life vest on it was sleeping
on the boat that's fun
what'd i say it it oh yeah that's how
you know somebody doesn't have a kid is
when they still refer to the kids
so then they ask them where's your mom
and he said she went swimming and didn't
come back
yes it's really sad yeah so i hope
we'll see what happens fingers crossed
fingers crossed
okay you sane
lunch money time well while she's trying
to get rich the rest of us just trying
to get her lunch money right
why did you have to end on such a sad
note
have a great day orange you glad see you
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block 5 so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block fight
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends